my my ask is this that um since we're
talking about tribes
um so I have friends from childhood and
high school and stuff like that they're
good-hearted people but the thing is
that they um they're not going anywh
with their lives so I'm I don't know
like I don't know if I should still be
friends with them and and don't make
them my main friends I've been told that
by psychologist but uh or should I just
be totally coldhearted and just be like
no I gotta let you go what do you think
I
would I would think that you would say
you gota let them go okay so you already
have the answer to your own
question so I guess so I guess my
question to you is why do you need to
ask that question if you already have
the answer to it because I mean like
part of the unplugging process is seeing
the out there and seeing the
in here as well right and if
you keep telling yourself stories like
well you know I've been friend friends
with them since I was in high school and
I should probably maintain that
friendship even though they're going
nowhere in life you see what I'm saying
like you're like you're lying yourself
no the reason why I asked it because I
asked the psychologist that and I don't
and something just didn't feel right
about it so I wanted to make sure with
you because you know you seem to know
more you the psychologist the same
question what do they say they said you
could still be friends with them but
don't make them your main
friends ah I mean
that's that's
the I guess that's the American
Psychological Association answer
everything you know the APA wants to uh
wants to water down everything um they
put out a a posting a few years ago
basically telling them to treat uh men
as toxically
masculine it it's not my advice right
because you got anchors and sales in
life sales fill with wind they take you
to your next Port AOL anchors hold you
back it's it's it's very very simple is
somebody that's in your life an anchor
or a sale if they're an anchor you cut
them loose you can't move forward if
they're anchoring you back there's a
video somewhere I put on my um Twitter
feed um and it keeps getting reposted uh
it's a video of Snoop Dog and he's
talking about how as you level up and
you get better then these people sort of
stay down over here and you keep getting
better and better and they either have
to come up to your level or you cut them
loose because you can't go down to their
level once you've left
right there's a dominance hierarchy in
the world and there's people that are up
here there's people that are further
than that there's people down at the
bottom and that's fine but as you move
forward you have to cut the anchors off
you can I mean if you want to remain in
loose contact as your psychologist
friend recommended see them at holidays
see them at Thanksgiving see them in
Christmas but you don't make any effort
to spend time with people that aren't
doing the work on themselves to level up
iron sharpens iron you want you want to
surround yourself with killers right so
you have to be fastidious about the
people that you spend time with one of
the things that you can do yourself run
that you can control within your own
universe and I'm hoping that you're
already working on this right now but
cutting the weight you know yeah right
100% mean I can see it all in your face
right now you know so you start you know
you start getting rid of that and you
start burning that off and you become
leaner and stronger more competent more
functional like all these things the
inflammation your body comes down you
just be more useful to yourself and you
know You' be more of a killer it'll be
more obvious to the world right you know
when you enter into a room because
you'll just look better yeah you're
right you know maximize look status
money game yet that was one of them I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clip's from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out